हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इनिंग टू
ऑल तो सबसे पहले आप लोग मुझे यह बता दीजिए
मेरी आवाज सबको साफसाफ सुनाई दे रही है आई
एम लाउड एंड
क्लियर बताइए एक बार
मुझे हेलो मोहम्मद हेलो हेलो एक बता द ओके
थैंक यू एवरीवन थैंक यू थैंक यू
ओके ओके थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो मिनट का
तो बाकी स्टूडेंट को जवाइन होने दीजिए तो
मुझे यह बताइए कि लास्ट क्लास में जो डे
17 थी जो हमने सीटीएफ परफॉर्म किया था
कमांड इंजेक्शन के थ्रू हमने रूट एक्सेस
गेन किया था और हमने दो फ्लैग तीन फ्लैग
जो हमने फाइंड आउट किए थे सबने कर लिया आई
एम
फाइन मैं अच्छा हूं आप लोग बताइए
ओके इट्स ओके अगर आपकी पहली क्ला क्लास है
कोई दिक्कत
नहीं तो आप लोग बताइए मुझे कि आप लोग कोई
भी आंसर नहीं कर रहा है आज की क्लास में
बताइए बताइए सबने किया
था
एवरीवन बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए ओके आज भी
जो नेक्स्ट क्लास करेंगे हम काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग है वोह भी उसमें कुछ और नई
चीजें सीखेंगे
हम उसके बाद हम धीरे-धीरे अपने लेवल को
बढ़ाएंगे
क लैपटॉप को क्यों नहीं कनेक्ट कर पा रहे
ओके मैं रिव्यू कर दूंगा जो मैं चेक करके
लिंक दिन
पर पता नहीं आज ओनली 36 स्टूडेंट्स है यह
हालत है आपके सिस्टम हैकिंग के
प्रैक्टिकल्स का यार देखिए आप आप लोग खुद
ही बताइए य यह हाल हमारा सिस्टम हैकिंग
का कोई नहीं हम क्लास में सबसे पहले जो
कमांड इंजेक्शन वटी क्या होती है उसका
इंट्रोडक्शन देन उसके बाद हम नेक्स्ट लैब
है जो हमारी जो हमारा नेक्स्ट सीटीएफ है
उसको परफॉर्म करेंगे और आज कुछ और नई
चीजें सीखेंगे हम कुछ नए टूल्स और कुछ नई
चीजें हम सीखेंगे हर रोज क्लास में कुछ
नया सीखेंगे
हम तो आज भी रेडी हो सभी लोग मेरे साथ
पार्टिसिपेट करने के लिए लाइव
में एवरीवन इ रेडी टू पार्टिसिपेट विद मी
प्रैक्टिस बाद में कर लिया करो आप और अभी
क्या है कि आप साथ के साथ मैं जो भी जो भी
सवाल आपसे पूछता हूं चाहे वह गलत हो चाहे
सही हो आपको उसका आंसर करना चाहिए ओके आर
यू रेडी एवरीवन क्लास को स्टार्ट करें
ओके चलो हम क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी
तो
यस तो लास्ट क्लास में हमने कमांड
इंजेक्शन वलन बिलिटी के बारे में पढ़ा था
कि कमांड इंजेक्शन वलन बिलिटी होती क्या
है मतलब उसको कैसे परफॉर्म किया था तो
उसका जो इंट्रोडक्शन था कि होती क्या है
और कितने टाइप्स की होती है मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन कर देता हूं स्लाइड के थ्रू देन
उसके बाद हम जो हमारी नेक्स्ट जो व
नेक्स्ट जो सीटीएफ है उसको परफॉर्म करेंगे
व्हाट इज कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी देखो कमांड
इंजेक्शन ओस कमांड इंजेक्शन इज आल्सो नोन
एज सेल इंजेक्शन या इसको हम आरसी भी बोल
सकते हैं रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन इट इज अ
वल्नरेबल दैट अलाउ एन अटैकर टू एग्जीक्यूट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कमांड्स ऑन द सर्वर दैट
इज रनिंग एन एप्लीकेशन
एंड ट टिपिकली फुल्ली कंप्रोमाइज
एप्लीकेशन एंड इट्स डटा फॉर एग्जांपल यह
मेरा एक सर्वर है वेब सर्वर है और ये
पब्लिक फेसिंग वेब सर्वर है और इसके ऊपर
एक वेबसाइट रन कर रही है जो हमने लास्ट
टाइम देखी थी पोर्ट नंबर 80 पर एक वेबसाइट
रन कर रही थी जिसके अंदर देखो आपने देखा
होगा कि उसके अंदर एक कमांड पैनल था जब
हमने
सक्सेसफुली इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के बाद हमने पोर्ट 80
के थ्रू जब हमने एंटर किया तो लॉग इन किया
हमारे पास क्रेडेंशियल हमने जब ब्लाइंड
क्रेशस को इंसर्ट किया तो हमने एक पैनल
मिला मतलब ये वेबसाइट थी वेबसाइट के अंदर
हमें एक कमांड पैनल मिला तो ये क्या है
एक्चुअल में यह जो वेबसाइट है किसके ऊपर
रन कर रही है किसके ऊपर आपके वेब सर्वर के
ऊपर रन कर रही है और यह वेब वेब सर्वर
कहां पर है आपकी एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का पार्ट
है जो पब्लिक फेसिंग वेब सर्वर है अब जब
अटैकर ने क्या किया इस वेबसाइट को विजिट
किया विजिट करने के बाद उसे उसने पाया कि
ओके इसमें कमांड इंजेक्शन लेबिलिटी है
बेसिकली क्या कर रहे हो आप यहां पर कुछ
ऐसा कोड बैक एंड में डिजाइन किया गया है
यह डायरेक्टली क्या करता है कि यूजर से जो
इनपुट ले रहा है उसको डायरेक्टली रन कर
रहा है किसके ऊपर आपके सर्वर के टर्मिनल
के ऊपर या सर्वर की कमांड के ऊपर रन कर
रहा है जिससे क्या हो रहा है बीच में कोई
भी सैनिटाइजेशन नहीं हो रहा है ना ही
इनपुट फिल्ट्रेशन हो रहा है मतलब यहां पर
कुछ भी मतलब बिल्कुल डायरेक्टली क्या है
और डायरेक्टली रन कर रहा आपके सर्वर पर तो
ये है वलन बिलिटी तो फ्रॉम ए बैक एंड कोड
पर्सपेक्टिव हाउ हाउ कैन दिस वटी बी
इंट्रोड्यूस इन टू योर एप्लीकेशंस ओके तो
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं फ्रॉम बैक एंड
कोड पर्सपेक्टिव हाउ दिस कैन बी टी
इंट्रोड्यूस योर एप्लीकेशन देखो इफ डेवलपर
अलाउ एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
कमांड्स यूजिंग इनबिल्ट फंक्शन ऑफ बैक एंड
कोड एंड डू नॉट वैलिडेट द क्लाइंट साइड
यूजर इनपुट इन दैट केस वेबसाइट इज
वल्नरेबल टू कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी हमारे
केस में यही हो रहा था कि आपके डेवलपर ने
वेबसाइट को डेवलप किया और कुछ इन बिल्ड
फंक्शन को यूज़ किया चाहे वो पीएचपी के है
चाहे वोह
python2 फंक्शन में क्या कि वो यूजर इनपुट
को इंसर्ट कर रहा था ले रहा था और उस
इनपुट को क्या डायरेक्टली क्या कर रहा था
सर्वर पे रन कर रहा था बिना उसको वैलिडेट
किए उसमें से जो कैरेक्टर्स होते हैं जो
आप बोलोगे
अ पता कैसे चलेगा पता चल जाता है आप उसको
ब्लाइंड हिट करके देखोगे ना तो आपको पता
चल जाता है कमांड इंजेक्शन वटी के बारे
में जैसे कि हमने परफॉर्म किया अभी यूआरएल
के अंदर भी मिल जाती है कई बार कमांड
इंजेक्शन टी मैं आपको बता दूंगा इसका अगर
प्रैक्टिकली आपको करना है तो कहां पर कर
सकते हो तो डेवलपर अलाउ एग्जीक्यूशन मतलब
अग डेवलपर आपको एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए अलाव
करता है यूजर इनपुट को डायरेक्टली जो आपका
जो सर्वर है उसके ऊपर एग्जीक्यूट करने के
लिए और उसको वैलिडेट नहीं करता है तो उस
केस में क्या है आपके कमांड इंजेक्शन वलन
बिलिटी मिलने के चांसेस होते हैं अभी जैसे
कि ये रहा टाइप्स ऑफ कमांड इंजेक्शन वनटी
वैसे तो दो टाइप्स की होती है कमांड
इंजेक्शन वनटी एक तो इन बैंड कमांड
इंजेक्शन दूसरी क्या होती है आपकी ब्लाइंड
कमांड इंजेक्शन इन बैंड कमांड इंजेक्शन
में क्या होता है इट अलाउ एन अटैकर
एग्जीक्यूटिंग कमांड्स ऑन द होस्ट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वाया वल्नरेबल एप्लीकेशन
एंड रिसीविंग द रिस्पांस ऑफ द कमांड इन द
एप्लीकेशन बेसिकली क्या करते हैं जब भी
क्या करोगे अगर वो इन बेंड कमांड इंजेक्शन
होगी तो डायरेक्टली जैसे आप क्या करोगे इन
यूजर इनपुट किया आपने तो उसका जो रिस्पांस
है वो आपके जो वेबसाइट है उसके ऊपर देखने
को मिलेगा चाहे वो आपके फ्रंट एंड में
आपके जो डिजाइन है उसके अंदर देखने को
मिले या आप उसके सोर्स कोड में रिव्यू
करोगे वहां पर देखने को मिले तो वो क्या
है आपका इन बैंड कमांड इंजेक्शन होता है
एक होता है ब्लाइंड कमांड इंजेक्शन इट
अलाउ एन अटैकर एग्जीक्यूटिंग कमांड्स ऑन द
होस्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वाया वेलेबल रनिंग
एप्लीकेशन दैट डज नॉट रिटर्न द आउटपुट
फ्रॉम द कमांड विद इन इट्स एचटीटीपी
रिस्पांस अब इस केस में क्या होता है यह
वनटी इस वनटी को एक्सप्लोइट करना इवेंट
कमांड इंजेक्शन वटी को एक्सप्लोइट करना
बहुत ज्यादा टिपिकल है क्यों क्योंकि इसका
आपको रिस्पांस देखने को नहीं मिलता इसका
आपको रिस्पांस देखने को नहीं मिलता तो
इसके कुछ तरीके हैं कि स्लिप कमांड चला के
या कुछ तरीके तरीके हैं जो आप क्या कर
सकते हो उससे हिट एंड ट्राई कर सकते हो कि
ओके कि माय मेरी जो वेबसाइट है वह कमांड
इंजेक्शन वल्नरेबल से अनेबल है या नहीं है
ये थी आपकी कमांड इंजेक्शन वलन बिलिटी अब
इसका इंपैक्ट क्या होता है इंपैक्ट ऑफ
कमांड इंजेक्शन वलन बिलिटी अन ऑथराइज
एक्सेस टू द एप्लीकेशन एंड होस्ट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम अगर हम कॉन्फिडेंशियल की बात करें
तो कमांड इंजेक्शन कैन बी यूज टू व्यू
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन ओबवियसली राइट है
इंटीग्रिटी की बात करें तो कमांड इंजेक्शन
कैन बी यूज टू अल्टर द कंटेंट ऑफ द
एप्लीकेशन यस अगर कमांड इंजेक्शन वलने
बिलिटी अवेलेबल है तो वहां पर क्या कर
सकते हो आप जो वेबसाइट है उसके कंटेंट को
चेंज भी कर सकते हो अवेलेबिलिटी की बात
करें तो आप उसके कंटेंट को डिलीट भी कर
सकते हो और साथ के साथ क्या रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आप चाहो
तो क्या कर सकते हो रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूट
करवा सकते हो वहां से रिवर्स सेल भी ले
सकते हो आप ये कमांड इंजेक्शन वल्नरेबल थ
तो ये काफी काफी डेंजरस और सीवियर
वल्नरेबल है यह टॉप 10 के अंदर आती है और
वाटप टॉप 10 2021 की बात करें तो ये नंबर
थ्री वटी इंजेक्शन वलने बिलिटी के अंदर
आती है ये तो ये थी आपकी कमांड इंजेक्शन
वनटी अगर आपको प्रैक्टिस करना है तो मैंने
आपको बताया था ट्राई हैमी पर एक कमांड
इंजेक्शन की एक लैब है वह आप परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो उससे आपको पता चल जाएगा कि कमांड
इंजेक्शन क्या होता है कैसे उसको परफॉर्म
किया जाए पर वो प्रीमियम लैब है लेकिन आप
लोग ने बोला सर हम प्रीमियम है नहीं
करेंगे तो एक और तरीका जहां पर आप इसको
क्या कर सकते हो प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो तो
एक पोर्ट्सविगर पर भी अवेलेबल इसकी लब पोट
स्विगर अकेडमी पर अवेलेबल है अगर आप लोगों
को नहीं पता तो वहां पर भी आप परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो देखो वेब सिक्योरिटी आप पढ़ भी
सकते हो और अकेडमी पर चलिए देन गो टू योर
व्यू लर्निंग मटेरियल
य और यहां पर आपको जाना है जाना है यह रहा
वे
द ओस कमांड इंजेक्शन यह रही इसके बारे में
एक्सप्लेन भी किया है कैसे इसको यूज किया
जा जाता है उसके बाद इसके बेस पर आपके लैब
भी अवेलेबल से यह रहे यह रहा ओस कमांड
इंजेक्शन सिंपल
केस ब्लाइंड ओएस कमांड वनटी के बेस पर भीय
था ब्लाइंड ओएस कमांड इंजेक्शन विद टाइम
डिलेज ब्लाइंड ओएस कमांड इंजेक्शन विद
आउटपुट रीडायरेक्शन ब्लाइंड ओस कमांड
इंजेक्शन विद आउट ऑफ बंड इंटरेक्शन
ब्लाइंड ओएस कमांड इंजेक्शन विद आउट ऑफ
बंड डाटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन तो यह तरीके हैं ये कुछ
स्लैब्स है जो आप परफॉर्म करके देख सकते
हो खुद से प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो य पढ़कर
और प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो कमांड इंजेक्शन
वलन बिलिटी की तो आई होप सबको मैं इसका
लिंक प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं चैट सेक्शन के
अंदर और कोई क् के रिलेटेड आपकी कमांड
इंजेक्शन आप मुझसे भी पूछ सकते हैं फिर हम
कंटिन्यू स्टार्ट करते
हैं आप यह पगर वाली जो लैब्स है उनको
परफॉर्म करोगे तो आपको कंप्लीट आईडिया हो
जाएगा ओके एवरीवन क्लियर की कमा इंजेक्शन
टी होती क्या है कितने टाइप्स की होती है
और फर्द आपको प्रैक्टिस करनी है तो
प्रीमियम लैब्स इ अवेलेबल ऑन द ट्राई हैक
मी एंड उसके बाद पोट्स विगर अकेडमी पर
जाकर भी आप क्या कर सकते हो इनकी लैब्स को
प्रैक्टिस में ले सकते हो यूज कर सकते हो
चलो चले स्टार्ट
करें
एवरीवन बताइए
यस मुझसे कैसे पूछोगे मुझसे डाउट पूछने का
एक ही तरीका है तरीका यह है कि आप जब सेशन
एंड हो जाता है सेशन एंड होने के बाद
रिकॉर्डिंग अवेलेबल रहती है आपकी
youtube1 क्लास में उसको एक्सप्लेन कर
दूंगा ओके चलो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी
अपनी लैब के साथ
दिस इज
आवर सबको स्क्रीन क्लियर दिखाई दे रही है
एवरीवन ओके यह रहा
ट्राई हैग पर चलते हैं
हम तो ट्राई हैग मी पर चलते हैं तो सबसे
पहले हम क्या करें अपनी लैब को सर्च करते
हैं सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है फंट
विजिबल है
एवरीवन आज की जो हमारी लैब है वह बाउंट
हैकर
बहुत ही बेसिक लैब है और अच्छी लैब है
मतलब बिगिनर्स के लिए काफी अच्छी लैब
है तो डायरेक्टली इसको क्या करते हैं मशीन
को स्टार्ट करते
हैं तो
एवरीवन आप लोग आज एक काम करना आप मेरा साथ
दीजिए आप लोग क्या ना सुरजीत मुखर्जी हम
क्या करते हैं ना अभी लाइव क्लास में
स्टूडेंट को परफॉर्म करने के लिए नहीं
बोलते आप चाहे तो परफॉर्म कर सकते हो अगर
आप में इतना कैलिबर है बट मैं आपको हमेशा
क्या बोलता हूं कि मैं आपसे क्वेश्चन
पूछूंगा और आप हमेशा चैट बॉक्स अपना ओपन
करके रखिए जिससे क्या होगा कि सेम टाइम
उसको रिप्लाई कीजिए कि जब कि मुझे अब मैं
आपसे नेक्स्ट स्टेप पूछू कि अभी मुझे क्या
करना चाहिए कौन सा टूल यूज करना चाहिए
क्या नहीं करना चाहिए ये साइज हम क्या
क्या इंटरेक्ट बनाते हैं अपने सेशन को
लास्ट क्लास में आपने देखा होगा उसके बाद
आप प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन करने वाला था कि लास्ट क्लास
में हमने क्या-क्या किया था और हमेशा क्या
है कि आप अपने नोट्स में अपनी जो
टैक्टिक्स है जो टेक्निक्स आपने यूज की कि
मैंने ए मैप टूल रन किया इतने पोर्ट मिले
इस पोर्ट प हमने इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की इस
टूल की हेल्प से इंफॉर्मेशन ये इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली हमने इसको ऐसे यूज कि ये सारे
स्टेप्स आपको लिख लेने चाहिए कहीं पर हर
एक लैब के हिसाब
से ओके तो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी आईपी
एड्रेस एक बार हमारा अलट अलट हो जाता है
है अभी तक आईपी एड्रेस आया नहीं व्हाट इज
द इशू ट आई डोंट
नो एक बार हम रिफ्रेश करते हैं इसको
ओके रिफ्रेश करना है समरी आपके सामने पुट
अप करनी तो ओके मैं जस्ट सेक एक बार हम
क्या करते हैं एक बार ओपन वीपीएन को
कनेक्ट करते हैं
ओके ओके सक्सेसफुली ओपन वीपीएन हमारा
कनेक्ट हो गया नया टैब यहां पर ओपन करते
हैं इस सेशन को नाम रख देते हैं हम ओपन
वीपीएन सो दैट की बीच में कन्फ्यूजन ना
हो एक बार फिर कंफर्म कर लेते
हैं ये रहा ओपन वीपीएन हमारा सक्सेसफुली
कनेक्ट हो गया इट्स ओके हम इसको स्क्रीन
को क्लियर कर देते हैं एक बार एक बार
टारगेट का आईपी एड्रेस मिल जाए हमें यह
रहा टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस हमारे सामने है और
व्हाट इज द इशू विद दैट लैब आई डोंट
नो क्रिएटेडॉक्युमेंट्सफ्रैगमेंट
दे 39
स्टूडेंट क्या कर लू यार मैं
ओके दिस इज आवर टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस हम
दोनों लैब्स को एक बार रिवाइज कर लेंगे
एंड में तो अभी मेरे पास आईपी एड्रेस है
तो मेरा पहला सवाल वही
है कि हम क्या करेंगे सबसे पहला
सवाल कि हमारे पास आईपी एड्रेस है तो सबसे
पहला मेरा सवाल यही है कि हम क्या करेंगे
अभी
नहीं नहीं मेरे पास आईपी एड्रेस है यह
मेरा आईपी एड्रेस है 10.10.1
6194 सबसे पहले मैं क्या करूंगा व्हाट विल
बी दवर फर्स्ट
स्टेप नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं आप मुझे यस हम
चेक करेंगे कि हमारी मशीन जो है वह एक्टिव
है या नहीं है फर्स्ट स्टेप हमारा हमेशा
होगा पिंग करना टारगेट को सो दैट वी कैन
फाइंड आउट कि अवर मशीन इज एक्टिव और नॉट
जिसको हम टारगेट कर रहे हैं तो उसके लिए
हम क्या करेंगे
पिंग पिंग हिट एंटर तो नाउ सक्सेसफुली
हमारी मशीन रिप्लाई कर रही है हमारे पैकेट
का तो इसका मतलब हमारी मशीन एक्टिव है ओके
अभी मुझे यह बताइए फिर से मेरा अगला सवाल
है इससे क्या इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल रही है
कि व्ट टाइप ऑ इंफॉर्मेशन इट इज
प्रोवाइड बताइए
यस च टाइप ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यस लिनक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यह हमने गैस किया है यह
हमारा गैस वर्क है बस हमने आईडिया लेगाया
लगाया अभी हम क्या करेंगे
इसको एजेक्ट अभी हमें क्या करना हरा गैस
वर्क कंप्लीट हो गया बट हम श्यर नहीं है
अभी हमें श्यर होने के लिए हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा फर्द इसके ऊपर इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
एन्यूमरेशन स्कैनिंग करनी होगी जिससे हम
धीरे-धीरे आगे अपनी इंफॉर्मेशन के बेस पर
क्या कंफर्म हो जाएंगे कि ये एक लिनक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है या विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है तो हम क्या करेंगे सबसे पहले
कौन सा टूल यूज
करेंगे अभी हम सबसे नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा
क्या
रहेगा व्हाट विल बी आवर नेक्स्ट
स्टेप यस हमारा नेक्स्ट स्प विल बी अवर
पोर्ट
स्कैन एन मैप डायरेक्टली कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व
हिट एंटर दिस इज आवर नेक्स्ट
स्टेप अभी 7 पर हुआ
है इट्स ओके
इट विल टेक टाइम क्योंकि मे भी ट्राई हैक
म के सर्वर्स बिजी है तो रिप्लाई कम कर
रहे हैं या मेरी मशीन थोड़ा स्लो
है हां अगर आप किसी भी कंपनी के लिए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग कर रहे हो जब आपको एज
ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर हायर कर लिया जाता है
या एज ए सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर या एज ए रेट
टीमर तो आपकी अप्रोच ऐसे ही रहती है आप
सीटीएफ क्या सीटीएफ का मतलब क्या है आप
उसमें फ्लैग फाइंड आउट कर रहे हो लेकिन
फ्लैग भी आप तभी फाइंड आउट कर पाते हो जब
उसके अंदर आपको कोई वलने बिलिटी मिलती है
अब वलने बिलिटी से पहले आपके पास
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी पती है तो रियल
सिनेरियो वही होते हैं सीटीएफ आपको हैबिल
बनाते हैं बस कि ओके मुझे ऐसे ऐसे परफॉर्म
करना है आपको रियल में भी पेन टेस्टिंग
ऐसे ही करनी होते है कि एन मैप टूल को आप
यूज करते हो जरूरत पड़ी तो आप मेट स् पलट
का यूज करते हो वनटी स्कैनिंग करते हो देन
उसके बाद एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते हो अगर आप
एक्सप्लोइट कर पा रहे हो एक्सप्लोइट हो
जाएगा तो उसके बाद पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फेज पे आते
हो ओके इट विल टेक टाइम
61.5 नहीं मेटा
स्प्लटर दो से तीन क्लास लिया है तो मेटा
स्लोट का तो बेसिक मैं कंप्लीट करवा चुका
हूं एडवांस मेटा स्ट तो दिस नॉट द पार्ट
ऑफ आवर कोर्स अगर आप लोगों को बूट कैंप
चाहिए तो आई विल प्रोवाइड द बूट कैंप बट
दैट विल बी
पेड यस अभी के लिए ओके अभी सर्वर की थोड़ी
सी प्रॉब्लम हो रही है हम मशीन को एक बार
फिर से टर्मिनेट और वो करते
क्योंकि 994 फिल्टर टीसीपी पोट नो
रिस्पांस क्लोज पोर्ट क्लोज पोर्ट मतलब
समथिंग एल्स समथिंग इज रंग क्योंकि ट्राई
हैक में सर्वर कुछ गड़बड़ कर रहा है तो हम
इसको एक बार क्लोज करते हैं देन फिर से हम
मशीन को ओपन करते हैं टर्मिनेट करते हैं
फिर से रन करते हैं
दोबारा
ना स्टार्ट द मशीन
कई बार होता है ट्राई हैक में के साथ होता
है नहीं आपकी मशीन पर डिपेंड करता है
दिया 48 स्टूडेंट्स ओके
के यस वी गट द आवर आईपी एड्रेस देन अगेन
अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं ओके शट
मैन व्हाट शुड आई
डू आई ब्रेक द कंप्लीट कनेक्शन बाय
मिस्टेक इट्स माय मिस्टेक आई एम सॉरी फॉर
ट यस इसको अभी सेशन का रिनेम कर देते
हैं ओपन वीपीएन अभी यहां पर सेशन को यूज
करते
हैं पिंग करते
हैं के आई थ मे बी सम प्रॉब्लम इ ट टुडे
आज ट्राई हैक मी सर्वर्स बहुत सारी
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट कर रहा
है कंट्रोल
सी कई बार ट्राई हैक के केस में होता है
है
यस अभी पिं कर रहे हैं नो इशू नो इशू नो
इशू नो इशू इट्स ओके इट्स वर्किंग
फाइन कंट्रोल सी एन मैप करते हैं हम एन
मैप उसके
बाद यह रहा
यस टेक 29.30 ओके इट विल टेक
टाइम नहीं बहुत स्लो नहीं है यार अभी मे
बी दिस टाइम इट वेरी स्लो क्योंकि डे टाइम
में जस्ट मैं इसको क्या करता हूं जब भी
क्लास आपको डिलीवर करनी होती है मैं एक
बार चीजें परफॉर्म करके देख लेता हूं कहीं
पर फेलियर तो नहीं है तो ट्राई हैक में
सर्वर वेरी फास्ट हर चीज को बहुत फास्ट
रिस्पांस कर रहा था तो य अभी आके अभी डाउन
हुआ थोड़ा सा हो सकता है ट्रैफिक ज्यादा
है तो सम टाइम्स इट हैपेंस
ओके कंट्रोल सी हम एक काम करते सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन के साथ करते हैं ओके तो जो
हमारा टास्क है तो सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
के साथ करते
हैं एन मैप हाइन सर्विस वर्जन देन उसके
बाद हम हाइन
t4 कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व के साथ करते ओके मे बी
इट विल वर्क
फास्ट डाउन बट ब्लॉकिंग आवर पिंग
रिक्वेस्ट इट्स ओके
अभी क्या कारण हो सकता है
बताइए होस्ट टीम्स डाउन इफ इट इज रियली अप
बट ब्लॉकिंग आवर पिंक
प्रोब क्या कारण हो सकता है बताइए अगर
आपके सामने प्रॉब्लम आ जाती है तो देन व्ट
यू डू क्या करोगे इस केस में
क्या करोगे इस केस
में मे बी चांसेस दैट कि आपने आपका फर्स्ट
टाइम मशीन पिंक कर रहा था वहां पर जो आपके
डिटेक्टर थे जो आपके डिफेंसिव साइड थे शोक
एनालिस्ट थे या नेटवर्क इंजीनियर थे या
जहां पर फायर वाल थी उनके किसी रोल को
इसने क्या कर दिया ट्रिगर किया जिसकी वजह
से हमारी पिंग रिक्वेस्ट को क्या कर रहा
है ये ब्लॉक कर रहा है वो तो हम करेंगे भा
शुभम वो हम करेंगे बट सर्वर इज नॉट बिजी
यह आपके रियल केस में हो सकता है कि आपने
जैसे ही उसको स्कैन करने की कोशिश की तो
आपके जो फायर वाल थे उनको पता चल गया आपका
जो क्लाइंट था उसको पता चल गया कि ओके
समवन ट्रांग टू पिंग मी तो वह एक्टिवेट हो
गए तो जिससे क्या हो उन्होंने रिस्पांस
करना बंद कर दिया ऐसे अल्टरनेट बहुत सारे
ऑप्श होते हैं उसको हम करेंगे डोंट वरी बट
अभी के लिए हम क्या करेंगे ओके ए मैप
हाइ फन पीएन सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन य बाकी
सारी चीजें रहेंगी अभी यह रहा अपना टारगेट
आईपी ट
एंटर ओके इट्स डन तो अभी हमारा जो टारगेट
आईपी है जो टारगेट मशीन है उसके ऊपर दे
थ्री पोर्ट्स आर ओपन पोर्ट नंबर 21 व एस
एफटीपीडी
3.0.3 पोर्ट नंबर 22 टीसीपी ओपन एसएसए 7.2
प2 नटू मशीन मतलब य एक लिनक्स मशीन है जो
हमने गेस किया था वह अभी हमने कंफर्म कर
लिया कि एक लिनेक्स मशीन है देन पोर्ट
नंबर 80 टीसीपी ओपन एचटीटीपी अचे
एचटीटीपीडी 2 प 2.4.18 य के साथ तो अभी
हमारे
पास एक इंफॉर्मेशन है कि हमारे पास तीन
सर्विसेस रनिंग कर रही है इस टारगेट के
ऊपर पोर्ट नंबर 21 पोर्ट नंबर 22 पोर्ट
नंबर 80 एफटीपी एसएसएस एचटीटीपी देन
नेक्स्ट अब हम क्या
करें नेक्स्ट मेरा क्वेश्चन नेक्स्ट व्हाट
वी डू अभी क्या
करेंगे बताइए
बताइए बताइए बताइए
ओके अखिलेश ने बोला सीएस एक्सप्लोइट कर
सकते हैं ओके
नेक्स्ट पोर्ट ए को विजिट कर सकते हैं
नेक्स्ट वल्नरेबल सर्विसेस
नेक्स्ट विजिट विजिट द
पोर्ट 22 टीसी स्कैन
करेंगे
नेक्स्ट स्कैन करेंगे
नेक्स्ट रीस्टार्ट
करेंगे और कुछ
और कुछ और किसी कोई
आंसर यस शुभम
ने एक स्क्रिप्ट का जिक्र किया है वनटी
स्कैन
ओके ओके मैक्सिमम लोगों ने ट्राई किया है
बताने का बट सही है कि हमें वन बाय वन
सर्विस के ऊपर नमरे करना है एन्यूमरेशन
मैंने आप लोगों को सिखाया था ना कि डे 14
डे 13 डे 15 में भी कि हम एन्यूमरेशन कैसे
परफॉर्म करते हैं कि एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन
एसएसएस नमरे या इवन आपको सर्वर नमरे मैंने
सिखाया था आप लोगों
को सभी को याद है नमरे मैंने आपको सिखाया
था यस तो ये आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है कि
हर एक सर्विस के ऊपर पर्टिकुलर सर्विस के
ऊपर एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करना क् आप लोग
बोल रहे सर हमें लैब नहीं मिल रही तो यह
आपके पास लैब है इसके ऊपर आप क्या कर सकते
हो फ्री लैब है एक्सेस करके वो सारी
स्क्रिप्ट वह सारे मॉड्यूस आप परफॉर्म कर
सकते हो व सारी मैनुअल टेक्निक्स य पर
परफॉर्म करके देख सकते कि व्ट टाइप
इंफॉर्मेशन आर यू गेटिंग तो अभी मैं एक नई
स्क्रिप्ट के बारे में आपको सिखाने वाला
हूं एन मैप के अंदर एक स्क्रिप्ट होती है
वनटी स्कैनिंग स्क्रिप्ट वलन स्कैन ओके
वलने बिलिटी स्कैन स्क्रिप्ट जिसको हम
बोलते बोलते हैं बेसिक वलने बिलिटी स्कैन
जैसे कि
एनम हाइन पीएन उसके बाद सर्विस वर्जन
हमारे पास है हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट हाइन
हाइन स्क्रिप्ट उससे बोलते हैं हम वलन
वनटी स्कन स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी
बेसिकली य स्क्रिप्ट करते क्या है व्हाट
इज द यूज ऑफ दिस स्क्रिप्ट किसी को पता है
व्हाट इज द यूज ऑफ दिस स्क्रिप्ट एनी
वन किसी को कोई आईडिया है व्हाट इज द यूज
ऑफ वटी स्कैन
स्क्रिप्ट एनी वन इज अवेयर
एनी वन इज
अवेयर यस आप गेस सही कर रहे हो क्योंकि एक
बेसिक वल्नरेबल स्कैनिंग स्क्रिप्ट है यह
क्या करती है आपकी जो बेसिक वलने बिलिटी
है या जो मोस्ट कॉमन वनटी होती है किसी भी
सिस्टम से रिलेटेड किसी भी मशीन से
रिलेटेड उनको क्या करते है य फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करती है अगर वह लेबिलिटी
अगेंस्ट द सर्विस किसके अंदर जो सर्विस
रनिंग है उस सर्विस के अंदर ही फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करती है उस सर्विस से
रिलेटेड उस सर्विस के अंदर उस सर्विस के
थ्रू ही मशीन की वनटी को फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करती है ठीक है बेसिक वनटी स्कैन
स्क्रिप्ट अगर वो वनटी सिस्टम के अंदर है
अवेलेबल है तो उसको क्या करता है विद सीवी
आईडी यह एन मैप अपने रिजल्ट में शो करता
है जैसे कि अभी हिट एंटर किया हमने तो इट
विल टेक टाइम बट डेफिनेटली यू गोट सम आंसर
अगर
मोस्ट कॉमन जो वल्नरेबल कीज हैं वो अगर
अवेलेबल है तो आपके मशीन के अंदर तो वह
आपको रिजल्ट में शो करेगी ये स्क्रिप्ट तो
बेसिकली हम इसको बोलते हैं बेसिक वलन बिटी
स्कैन या वल्नरेबल स्कैनिंग स्क्रिप्ट या
इसको हम बोल सकते हैं इट अगर कोई पूछता कि
व्हाट इज द यूज ऑफ दिस स्क्रिप्ट इट स्कैन
द बेसिक वल्नरेबल या बेस मोस्ट कॉमन वनबिल
इनसाइड ए मशीन बस इसका रीजन यही है मतलब
इसका यूसेज यही है यूज केस
पता चल
गया साधु कान आई एम सॉरी फॉर द प्रोन
पलब ओके सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए देखो इट इ
ट्रांग यह अभी टाइम लेगा थोड़ा
सा तो सभी को पता चल गया व्ट इज द यूज केस
ऑफ द वलन
स्कैन एम इन व आपका जो डाउट आप बोल सर इज
इन थ्री वे हैंड शेकिंग इफ सर्वर इज बिजी
इट नॉट रेस्पॉन्डिंग आवर रिक्वेस्ट तो
इट्स देन रिस्पांस होस्ट डाउन कुछ भी का
कारण हो सकता है मैं आपको श्यर नहीं बोल
रहा कि फायर वाल ट्रिगर हुआ है बट ये आपका
अजमन होना चाहिए कि अगर आप जब पेन
टेस्टिंग करें तो हमेशा यही नहीं बोल सकते
कि सर्वर डाउन क्योंकि सर्वर इज बिजी हो
सकता है कि आप ब्लाइंड यही सवाल करके अपने
आप से उसको उसी चीज से आप उसको बार-बार
हिट कर रहे हो जिससे क्या होगा अगर सर्वर
बिजी नहीं होगा और आपकी मशीन को रिक्वेस्ट
पिंग रिक्वेस्ट है उसको रिस्पांस नहीं कर
रहा होगा ठीक है और वहां पर कोई आईडीएस
होगा इंट डिटेक्शन सिस्टम तो कंटिन्यू सली
आपको लॉक करता रहेगा और फिर उस परे आपके
आपके अगेंस्ट क्या करेंगे या तो आईपी
ब्लॉक करेंगे आपके अगेंस्ट वो पेन
टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट करना स्टार्ट कर देंगे
ओके तो समझ पा रहे हो कि आपको हर एक
सिनेरियो से सोचना है जस्ट नॉस्ट जस्ट
अकेला एक सिनेरियो प नहीं सोचना आपको हर
एक सिनेरियो जितने भी होते हैं सब पर
सोचना है
नहीं अभी स्कैनिंग कर रहा है इट विल टेक
टाइम क्योंकि ऑलरेडी स्लो चल रहा है तो इट
विल टेक
टाइम यस एन मैप एक ऐसा टूल्स है जो आपको
बता देता है कि अगर आपने एन मैप टूल्स के
बारे में अगर सही से सीखा होगा मैं ने
आपको अपनी लास्ट क्लास मतलब लास्ट जो
स्टार्टिंग की क्लासेस थी एमफ के बारे में
काफी डिटेल में सिखाया अगर उनको आपने
ध्यान से सीखा होगा और टीसी पे है वे हैंड
चक का आपको कांसेप्ट क्लियर है तो आप उन
दोनों के बेस पर यह फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
कि बिहाइंड द जो आप जिसको स्कैन कर रहे हो
सर्वर के आगे फायरवॉल भी हो सकती है आप
उससे आईडिया लगा सकते हो मैंने हर एक
सिनेरियो आपको वहां पर क्लियर किया था
और कुछ बताइए तब
तक मतलब मैं समझा
नहीं तो मुझे यह बताइए कि जो एफटीपी है और
एसएसएस इन दोनों पर और क्याक कर सकते हो
आप और क्याक ट्राई कर सकते हो आप एसएसएस
और एफटीपी पर आप क्याक ट्राई कर सकते हो
यस रिकन इ द मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
स्टेप यस वेरी गुड शुभम वेरी गुड वेरी गुड
अग कोई वक थ्रो तो फॉलो नहीं कर रहा यहां
पर कि साइड में बस वाक थ्रो को देख के बता
बता रहे
हो यह चीटिंग होगी
98 पर हो गया है तो इट विल टेक सम सेकंड
मे बी वन मिनट मैक्स
यस मेटा पलट का आप यूज कर सकते
हो इतने भोले मत बनिए कि आप लोगों को यह
तक नहीं पता वाक थ्रो क्या होता
है इतने भोले मत
बनिए अब सीटीएफ परफॉर्म करने में यही
प्रॉब्लम है कि आप एक क्लास में वन एंड
हाफ आवर की क्लास में एक सीटीएफ को कभी
परफॉर्म नहीं कर पाओगे आपको एटलीस्ट अगर
आपका सीटीएफ अगर अच्छा होगा जिसमें बहुत
सारे कांसेप्ट इवॉल्व हो जाएंगे उस केस
में क्या है कि आपको दो से तीन क्लास कवर
करनी पड़ जाएंगे और ऐसा हमारे साथ होगा
क्योंकि बहुत सारे कांसेप्ट है जैसे मैंने
आप पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन का कांसेप्ट है वह
मुझे आपको सीटीएफ के थ्रू एक्सप्लेन करना
है तो वो डेफिनेटली टू थ्री क्लासेस
लगेंगी और जैसे कुछ ऐसे हैं जैसे कि जब हम
एक्सप्लोइट कैसे फाइंड आउट करते हैं और
एक्सप्लोइट फिर हम उसको फिक्स कैसे करते
हैं एक फाइल को मुझे ट्रांसफर कैसे करना
है और उसके बाद रिवर्स सेल कैसे लेना है
तो ये भी सारे पार्ट आपके सिप्स के बीच
में तो ये सारी चीजें सिखाने के लिए क्या
कुछ तो चीजें ऐसे कि इंडिविजुअल क्लास
रहेंगी उनके ऊपर बट वो आपके वाय सीटीएफ
होंगे
समझाऊ समझाऊ शुभम ये ओके तो रिजल्ट हमारे
सामने आ गया तो अभी जो स्कैनिंग हुई
स्कैनिंग के बेस पर देखो पोट 20 एफटीपी से
रिलेटेड कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन हमें नहीं मिली
एसएसएस से रिलेटेड हमें कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली और एचटीटीपी के रिलेटेड हमें कुछ
मिला देखो एचटीटीपी स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस कुड
नॉट फाइंड एनी स्टोर्ड एक्सेस वटी ओके कुड
नॉट फाइंड एनी सीएसएस सीएसआर ऑफ वल्नरेबल
ओके कुड नॉट फाइंड एनी डोम बेस्ड एक्सएसएस
नहीं मिली ओके इंटरनल आईपी डिस्क्लोजर ये
तो क्या है लोकल आईपी है मशीन के पास और
अबी ये बता रहा है आपको एचटीटीपी स्लोज
चेक किया कि वल्नरेबल है इससे डोस अटैक से
वल्नरेबल है लाइक वल्नरेबल उसकी सीवी आईडी
प्रोवाइड की है देन उसके बाद डिस्क्लोजर
डेट है इसकी नाउ सेकंड चीज क्या उन्होंने
एचटीटीपी एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म किया वहां से
उन्होंने जो इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट की कि
यह बता रहा है कि इस मशीन के ऊपर यह जो
डायरेक्टरी है इमेजेस नाम की डायरेक्टरी
क्या है अवेलेबल है तो बेसिकली क्या
इन्होंने डायरेक्टरी जब हम डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म करते थे डर बस्टर के
थ्रू या गो बस्टर के थ्रू परफॉर्म करते
हैं तो वही चीज इसने क्या किया अपने लेवल
पे जो बेसिक वटी स्कैन के थ्रू इन्होंने
यह बताया कि एक इमेजेस नाम की एक क्या है
डायरेक्टरी अवेलेबल है पोर्ट नंबर 80 के
ऊपर ओके अभी मुझे एक चीज है मैं एक सवाल
है आप लोगों से पूछना चाहता हूं
कि यह बता रहा है कि यह डोस अटैक से
वल्नरेबल
है लेकिन क्या हमें डोस अटैक करना है इस
लैब में
बताना
यस क्या मुझे इसमें डोस अटैक करना
है नो क्योंकि हमारा मोटो क्या है हमारा
ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या है पहले मुझे आप लोग यह
बताइए कि व्हाट इज अवर ऑब्जेक्टिव
व्हाट इज आवर
ऑब्जेक्टिव हमारा ऑब्जेक्टिव
है सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन को निकालना सर्वर
से उसके लिए हमें क्या करना है एक्सप्लोइट
करना है और एक्सप्लोइट करके हमें सर्वर के
अंदर एक्सेस लेना है और एक्सेस लेने के
बाद हमें सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन को
डिस्क्लोज करना है यही हमारा मोटो है नहीं
हमारा मोटो कमांड इंजेक्शन नहीं है
आज रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन लेना एक ही मोटो
नहीं है हमारा हमें अलग-अलग टाइप्स के
अटैक परफॉर्म करने हैं एक ओनली कमांड
इंजेक्शन ही नहीं है कमांड इंजेक्शन में
प्रीवियस लब से रिलेटेड था व कांसेप्ट मैं
आपको पढ़ा चुका हूं ओके तो अभी मुझे
एचटीटीपी के केस में इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई है
तो मैं खुद से भी फाइंड आउट कर सकता था
किसके बेस पर ब्राउजर के आधार पर ठीक है
जो ब्राउजर है उसमें मैं पोर्ट नंबर 80 के
को सर्च कर
अगेंस्ट दिस आईपी तो मुझे वहां पर
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती बट मेरा ट मैं किसम
इंटरेस्टेड हूं ज्यादातर अभी एफटीपी और
एसएसएस अभी जब हमने डे 14 की क्लास में
एफटीपी सर्वर के बारे में डिस्कस किया था
कि एफटीपी होता क्या है फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल्स मैंने वहां पर एक चीज आप
लोगों के साथ डिस्कस की थी कि वह क्या था
कि एफटीपी सर्वर को आप एक्सेस दो ही तरीके
तरीकों से कर सकते हो एक तो कौन सा
कौन-कौन से दो तरीके हैं जिनके थ्रू आप
क्या कर सकते हो एटीपी सर्वर को एक्सेस कर
सकते
हो ओके तो देखो दो तरीके से यार आप लोग
नहीं
है पता नहीं क्या कर रहे हो मैं आप लोगों
से सवाल पूछ रहा हूं आप लोग रिप्लाई भी
नहीं कर रहे और मैं आपसे पूछा कि एफटीपी
सर्वर को दो तरीके से हम एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं जो मैंने डे 14 की क्लास में आप लोगों
के साथ डिस्कस किया था तो वो दो तरीके कौन
से
हैं
दो रिवर्स सेल से हम एक्सेस कर सकते हैं
कमांड प्रोमट से हम एक्सेस कर सकते हैं
ब्रूट फोर्स से एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं
बताइए मैंने आपको डे 14 क्लास में यह
बताया था कि एफटीपी को दे ओनली टू वे थ्रू
विच वी कैन एक्सेस वन वे यूजर नेम एंड
पासवर्ड क्रेडेंशियल जिनको हम बोल सकते
हैं यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड होने चाहिए आपके
पास एक तरीका तो आपके पास ये होता है
दूसरा अगर आपका एफटीपी सर्वर मिस
मिस कन्फे गर्ड का मतलब क्या है कि आपका
एफटीपी सर्वर पब्लिकली एक्सेसिबल है उसको
कोई भी एक्सेस कर सकता है विदाउट
ऑथेंटिकेशन बिना पासवर्ड के जस्ट एक
एनोनिमस यूजर का यूज करके तो उसको हम
बोलते हैं एफटीपी एन एन ऑन वल्नरेबल ओके
अगर आपका सर्वर मिस कन्फर्टी पी एन ऑन
वल्नरेबल से एफटीटी ए एन ऑन का मतलब क्या
है एफटीपी एनोनिमस वल्नरेबल से वल्नरेबल
है तो आप क्या कर सकते हो उसको डायरेक्टली
एक्सेस कर सकते हो विदाउट यूजर नेम एंड
पासवर्ड जस्ट वहां पर आपको जो यूजर नेम
यूज करना है वो कौन सा आपका एनोनिमस ओके
दूसरा तरीका अगर आपका एफटीपी सर्वर एफटीपी
अननोन वलने बिलिटी से क्या नहीं है
वल्नरेबल नहीं है तो उस केस में आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करना होगा
अभी हम सबसे पहले चेक करते हैं ए मैप के
अंदर एक स्क्रिप्ट होती है एफटीपी एन नोन
जिसके थ्रू मैं ये पता लगा सकता हूं कि जो
मेरा एफटीपी सर्वर है वो एफटीपी नॉन वनबिल
से वल्नरेबल है या नहीं है तो एन मैप एन
मैप हाइन पी एन देन उसके बाद हाइन न
स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद एफटीपी
अननोन उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस यह मैं
चेक करता हूं हिट
एंटर कितने स्टूडेंट का फर्स्ट डे आज
क्लास
में कितने स्टूडेंट्स ऐसे हैं जिनका आज
पहला दिन है क्लास
में शुभम आप डे वन से क्लास में आ रहे हो
और यह चीज मैं आपको नहीं बताऊंगा कि यह
सारी स्क्रिप्ट कहां पर मिलेंगे
ओके मैं य क्लास में ल डाउन ही बताऊंगा
मैं ओके तो यहां पर देखिए एफटीपी एनन
स्क्रिप्ट आपको बता रही कि एफटीपी एनोनिमस
एफटीपी लॉगिन इज अलाउड ओके और कैन नॉट गेट
डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग टाइम आउट ओके यहां पर
टाइम आउट होगा इट्स ओके मतलब वी आर श्यर
कि जो आपका एफटीपी सर्वर है जो इस मशीन के
ऊपर रनिंग है वो वेनेबल है कौन सी वनटी से
एफटीपी एनोनिमस वलन बिलिटी तो उसको एक्सेस
करने के लिए हम कैसे यूज कर सकते हैं
एफटीपी आपका टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस और हिट
एंटर अभी सर्वर आपका स्लो चल रहा है तो
इसलिए रिस्पांस स्लो कर रहा है
इट इज वेरी स्लो यार वेरी वेरी वेरी
स्लो ऐसे तो लैब हम दो दो दिन में परफॉर्म
कर पाएंगे ऐसे इट इज वेरी
स्लो यस अखिलेश आप उसका भी यूज कर ल स्कनर
एफटीपी एनोनिमस का भी यूज कर सकते हो यह
फाइंड आउट करने के
लिए नहीं आप कंप्लेन नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि
प्रॉब्लम इज ट की ट्रैफिक ज्यादा होगा और
अभी साथ के साथ आप देखो य आ गया एनोनिमस
एनोनिमस देन यूजर नेम यूजर नेम एनोनिमस और
पासवर्ड हम ब्लैंक छोड़
देंगे स्पेलिंग मे बी राइट माय स्पेलिंग इ
राइट
एवरीवन कक द बॉस में
यार पेड रहते हैं मैक्सिमम फ्री कब मिलता
है तो कक द बॉक्स को भी हम यूज करेंगे बट
अभी जरूरत नहीं है हमें
बहुत स्लो एफटीपी सर्वर भी स्लो कर रहा
रिस्पांस आई डोंट न ट द इ वि
ट यह
देखिए और आई थिंक कि वी आर नॉट एबल टू
कंप्लीट द लैब
टुडे जो मुझे लग
क्यक इट्स वेरी स्लो ओके लॉगिन फेल्ड आई
डोंट नो भाई लॉगिन फेल स्पेलिंग गलत थी
क्या
हमारी तो मे बी एफटीपी लॉगिन फी वट इ इ वि
ट न बाय
एफटीपी कंट्रोल शिफ्ट
व नहीं कैपिटल ए का इशू नहीं
है इट इज वेरी वेरी स्लो
लॉगिन सक्सेसफुल हमने सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन
कर लिया नाउ अभी हम क्या करते
हैं एलएस करते इसके अंदर यह
रहा 29 एंटरिंग एक्सटेंडेड पैसिव मोड ओके
तो एक चीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं यहां पर
कि जगर अगर आपको एफटीपी का एनोनिमस लॉगिन
मिल रहा है आपको अगर एफटीपी सर्वर एनोनिमस
इज मिस
कन्फर्स केस में फिर आपके जो यूजर्स है जो
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड को ब्रूट फोर्स करने की
जरूरत नहीं है अगर आपको मिस कंफिल रहा है
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है सिंपली उस
एनोनिमस एफटीपी सर्वर के अंदर लॉग इन करना
है लॉग इन करने के बावजूद आपको क्या करना
है डायरेक्टरीज और फाइल्स को फाइंड आउट
करना है कि कौन-कौन सी फाइल्स और
डायरेक्टरीज अवेलेबल एफटीपी सर्वर के अंदर
और एक चीज है कि एफटीपी सर्वर के अंदर आप
कैट नहीं कर सकते कैट का मतलब क्या होता
है कि आप वहीं पर फाइल को रीड नहीं कर
सकते एफटीपी की सर्वर की फाइल को आपको
क्या करना होगा अपनी मशीन के ऊपर डाउनलोड
करना होगा और डाउन ड करने के बाद आप उनको
क्या कर सकते हो रीड कर सकते हो समझ में आ
गया ना क्या होता देखो इसका भी एक मतलब
होता आपको देखो यह रहा हम सिंपली इसको
क्या कर कॉपी करते हैं और चलते हैं य
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक ओके पेस्ट एंड को इसका
मतलब क्या होता देखो एफटीपी प्रॉब्लम एंट
एक्सटेंडिंग पस मो य यह क्या है
[संगीत]
एक कहीं पर मैंने इससे रिलेटेड पढ़ा
था यह रहा यह रहा
होगा कहीं एक फॉर्म प से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन थी ये इसका पार्ट ऐसा कुछ नहीं
है ये रहा कि हाय आई ट्राइड सेंडिंग
समथिंग लाइक दैट
एंड से मोड आई स्पेंड फोर डेज कंपलीटिंग
माय मनी ट्रांसफर एंड यह कुछ सम वेयर क्या
कि है इसका कनेक्शन जब आप कनेक्शन जब आपका
एफटीपी सर्वर काफी बिजी होता है व कनेक्शन
एस्टेब्लिश करने की कोशिश करता है या जब
भी आप उसके अंदर कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करते हो एलएस करते हो या गेट करते हो
डाउनलोड करते हो या आप उसके अंदर पुट करते
हो मतलब इंसर्ट करते हो तो उस केस में अगर
आपका एफटीपी सर्वर काफी बिजी है आपका
सर्वर स्लो है तो उस केस में क्या सबसे
पहले यह एक यह लाइन आती है यह कनेक्शन
स्टब के एस्टेब्लिश की लाइन होती है ये आप
देखोगे
तो जसवंत सिंह मतलब क्या है आपका
का मतलब क्या
है यर आई एम डाइंग राइटिंग समथिंग लाइक ट
ये है
ओके ओ तो ये रहा नाउ अभी सक्सेसफुली हमने
क्या किया एंटर कर लिया एरर आएगी इसके
अंदर दो फाइल है log.txt और टास्क t एकटी
log.txt और टास्क t एकटी इनको हम क्या कर
लेते हैं डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं तो डाउनलोड
करने के लिए गेट कमांड होती है देन उसके
बाद लक्स डटी एकटी लॉक्स डटी एकटी
जसवंत सिख एक काम कीजिए
आप फ्री में अपलोड करके
देखिए मैं आपको चैलेंज कर रहा
हूं करो आप फ्री
अपलोड करो
करो यस मान सिंह शर्मा ने जो आपको आंसर
दिया लॉक्स डटी एक्सटी
गेट नॉट
कनेक्टेड समथिंग प्रॉब्लम विज दैट मशीन तो
आज मुझे लगता है सेशन को एंड करना ही
पड़ेगा काफी हैंग कर रही है हमारी मशीन तो
मुझे लगता है कि सेशन को कल करना पड़ेगा
इस क्लास को कंटिन्यू
कल करें सेशन को एंड करें आज मैं भी
क्योंकि मशीन काफी लोड नहीं ले रही तो
हमें शायद सेशन को कल कंटिन्यू करना होगा
इधर से
ही यस हुसैन
बोलिए क्योंकि स्टार्टिंग से मशीन आज
हमारी लोड नहीं ले रही पता नहीं व्ट इ द
इशू विद ट तो आज मुझे लगता है कि आई एम
सॉरी फॉर दैट कि आज नहीं कर पाएंगे हम
इसको परफॉर्म पता नहीं व्ट इ द इशू मैं भी
नहीं समझ पा रहा कि क्या इशू आ रहा
है बताइए गाइस आप लोगों को क्या लगता है
सेशन को एंड कर देना चाहिए आज
ओके देखते हैं
अखिलेश इट्स ओके आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट इसके
लिए मुझे थोड़ा सा आज के लिए वेरी वेरी
रियली सॉरी क्योंकि आज जो हमारी लैब है
ट्राई हैक म सर्वर का काफी इशू आ रहा है
मैं कुछ भी चाह के नहीं कुछ भी कर पाता
क्योंकि हर एक स्टेप एक दूसरे स्टेप पर
परफॉर्म डिपेंडेंट है
तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट टुडे तो मे बी मुझे
लगता है कि शायद थोड़ा लेट करना पड़ेगा इस
टाइम पे काफी लैब बिजी हो रही है तो आई
विल थिंक अबाउट इट कि एक बार और परफॉर्म
कर नहीं 60 पर सॉल्व नहीं हुआ है अभी तक
क्योंकि इसमें बहुत कुछ टेक्निक्स है
टैक्टिक्स है इसको सॉल्व करने की क्योंकि
ये एक नक्स हैकिंग की लैब है मतलब बेसिकली
आप क्या प्रिविलेज एस्क लेशन आज फर्स्ट एक
पहला स्टेप सीखने वाले थे प्रिविलेज एस्क
लेशन का बिल्कुल जस्ट डेमो
स्टेप यस मुझे लगता कि थोड़ा सा या तो
हमें 8 बजे रखना चाहिए सेशन या आई विल
ट्राई हम देखते
हैं सैटरडे संडे को हो सकता है इट्स फाइन
अगर आप लोग रेडी हो
तो ओके तो तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर गाइ और सेशन
को एंड करते हैं और कल करते हैं इसको 100%
कल ट्राई करते हैं इसको कल भी क्लास होगी
कंटिन्यू करेंगे इस लैब को तो कल कंटिन्यू
करते हैं इसको तो बाय बाय टेक केयर और अगर
किसी का कोई सवाल है तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
यस आप लोग भी ट्राई
कीजिए काली को पेन ड्राइव में डाउनलोड तो
कर लोगे इशू है आपके साथ क्या उसको अपडेट
करोगे ना फिर अपडेट और अपग्रेड तो हो नहीं
पाएगा आसानी से उसी वर्जन में
चलेगा या वी विल कंटिन्यू टुमारो
डेफिनेटली श्यर इस लैब को हम कंप्लीट
करेंगे देन ही
हम नेक्स्ट सेशन के बीच में गैप लेंगे
मॉर्निंग में 10 पीएम के बाद तो नॉट
पॉसिबल बट इसी टाइम पर हम ट्राई करेंगे
सभी का आता है 229 ये कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश
करने का कुछ है
इनका नहीं डायरेक्ट करने से कुछ भी नहीं
होगा यस टुमारो वी विल टेक द
क्लास तो बाय बाय एंड टेक केयर गुड नाइट
और सी यू फॉर टुमारो
आपको व ग्रुप में मिल जाएगा
टाइमिंग ताकि लैब थोड़ा सा चल पड़ेगी मुझे
लगता कि मेरी मशीन अभी मॉर्निंग से रन कर
रही है तो हो सकता है कि उसके कारण भी
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो रही हो तो आई एम सॉरी
फॉर दैट चलो सेशन को कंटिन्यू करते हैं
बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर टुमारो